evening and welcome to fox news
primetime i'm lawrence jones
tonight there are two very different
stories planned out on the immigration
front
one is in american southwest and one is
in washington
the first you're hearing a lot about the
second
you're not and what happened today tells
you
everything you need to know about where
joe biden and his elite silicon
valley friends are taking our country of
course you've heard
about the crush of migrants storming our
southern border
biden called them here repeatedly
throughout the campaign not only have
they
arrived tens of thousands or more are
coming
you've seen the pictures they are
heartbreaking thousands of women
children waylay in mexico
desperately praying for permission to
enter america and ask for asylum
little do they know their kids may soon
end up
in containers now the white house isn't
worried about this
president biden shows no sign of remorse
and if you
ask him to comment on this so-called
crisis at the border
did you receive a briefing about the
border today uh
yes i did what did you learn a lot is
there a crime
[Applause]
[Music]
the men and women of the department of
homeland security
are working around the clock seven days
a week
to ensure that we do not have a crisis
at the border
but that is just the first immigration
disaster they don't want you to see
the second is much harder to spot and
it's unfolding right now
quietly in the halls of congress and
they're energy-efficient skyscrapers of
silicon valley
when they see these pictures as
agonizing as they may be
they spot opportunity they always do
today the heads of america's largest
companies led by big tech of course
sent a letter to congress demanding
immediate action on
immigration reform what kind of action
good question they're not asking for
food shelter
or medical uh supplies for migrants
they're not asking for faster processing
of asylum claims they're not even asking
to release the kids from the containers
no they're asking congress to provide an
immediate pathway to citizenship
not for the migrants but for the
dreamers people
already that live here in this country
illegally
maybe some of them work for big tech the
bottom line is
this has nothing to do with the people
waiting
in line president trump went down the
same road
in his early days of his presidency and
they nod them
they called him a racist these same
corporations are now testing our new
president joe biden
and their letter was not a request
though it may read that way
it was a threat just read the small
print
for yourself quote if congress fails to
act
our economy could lose 350 billion in
gdp
and the federal government could lose 90
billion in tax revenue
delay or inaction will cause significant
negative economic and social impact
okay so if we don't give them what they
want
what they want they'll just take the
economy see
this isn't about compassion it's about
their bottom line it always is whether
it is
cheap labor in fulfillment warehouses or
highly skilled programmers
from south asia that is who they are
fighting for this is not about you
the hard-working american taxpayers it
is always
about them you you're too stupid to work
at google
go build solar panels while we find your
replacements overseas
while you're at it complain about it on
facebook so they have a reason to kick
you off
it is the exact opposite of america
first
this is literally america last in the
middle of an economic crisis
so is joe biden on board with this
president biden chuck schumer mr
mcconnell
what side are you on